all right we
we are now live for this month it's
october 2020.
month's conversation about political
theory and
practice and i thought oops
says that connection is unstable uh
isn't that typical um let's see
if we can't get in on that me uh there
we go
had a condition
unstable for the internet for for a
minute
uh we've had a lot of high winds here so
this month uh
for political theory and discussion
obviously we've got a lot of big stuff
coming up
as we lean into the elections here in
the united states that are happening
and um i thought though since this is
sort of the the season of stoicism we
just finished
stoicon 2020 the big online conference
and i think we i mean we had 1500 people
i think we might have got about 1800
people for that
and stoic week starts tomorrow that may
be for the political theory
and discussion thing i would focus it on
how stoicism as a virtue ethics as a
classical intentional approach to life
would inform politics and so par
i'm not using notes for this one i'm
just going to kind of go off the cuff
and then engage with
people's questions but there are quite a
few things i i do want to bring up
and go through that might be
helpful for people because there's a lot
of misinformation out there
about what stoicism is and about
what its implications for anything
social or
political would be so let's start with
something that's really important there
is a difference
between what we call lower case s
stoicism
which is a personality trait the stiff
upper lip
nonsense that people have been preaching
for years and years don't show emotions
repress emotions
be a tough guy that's stoicism of the
lowercase s
that's not what we're talking about here
which is stoicism with an
uppercase s which is the actual
philosophy
um you know what you can find in what we
typically call the big three seneca
epictetus and marcus aurelius but what
you can also find
discussed in cicero uh even by opponents
of the stoics like plutarch
digested in diogenes laertes and aries
dynamis epitome of stoic ethics and of
course in
heracles and sonius rufus to stoic
philosophers that we don't have complete
texts of as we'd like to but we have
quite a bit of and so
if you want to talk about stoicism and
you want to you know be well informed
you have to read those texts there's
you can't just read you know summaries
or digest
by contemporary stoics i mean if you're
going to do that read the good stuff
like lawrence becker's a new stoicism
which is a head cracker of a book
or read you know margaret graver
stoicism on emotions or
read chris gill or read you know uh
you know books by other of my colleagues
like donald robertson or
or massimo pigliuchi don't read the you
know stoicism in five easy steps or
anything like that because you're going
to get some watered-down
pap that's not really helpful
so that that's one thing to say right
off the bat
now what do stoics actually
have to say about politics about the
political
sphere about how we ought to live our
lives together part of that has to do
with the fact that as human beings we
have a nature
and that nature is not an
individualistic nature
from the stoic standpoint there are
plenty of people who are individualists
and would stress you know their own
self-interest above everybody else or
their liberty
or whatever you want to call it that is
antithetical to the stoic doctrine
the stoic doctrine is that we are
social creatures we are intended to live
in society we have roles and duties and
obligations that stem
from that social nature and if we
want to be fully realized human beings
we need to pay attention to that and we
need to continually think out what the
obligations and requirements of that
would be
now i think a lot of people so again i'm
going to talk about a misunderstanding
of stoicism and this is one that
actually stems from
something that is genuinely stoic many
people try to summarize stoicism with
what's been
come to be called the dichotomy of
control there are some things in your
control
and some things that are not in
epictetus is words because that's where
these are coming from
some things that are mean meaning
they're up to us
notice he doesn't say up to you he says
to us there's a shared human nature
there right
um they're up to us they are our
business
they're they're the thing that we should
be primarily concerned with and then
there's things that are
in meaning they're they're really not up
to us they they're in somebody else's
control
and maintaining that distinction turns
out to be incredibly
important many of the things outside of
our control are what we call
externals uh to ecta in in greek
the things that are not without any
value whatsoever
as a matter of fact oftentimes they're
quite important but they're not what
make us good or bad people so heaping up
a ton of money
doesn't make you a good or bad person i
mean it may induce you to be a jerk in
which case you are a bad person
by virtue of being a jerk that's
something in your control
our bodies to some degree are outside of
our control our social
status and reputation outside of our
control
epictetus does not say ignore all that
stuff
none of that matters that is a
misinterpretation of stoicism
as a matter of fact if you read
epictetus and you
go through his texts you will find him
saying things that are
indifferent things that are externals
things that are outside of our control
they may be indifferent our use of them
our attitudes towards them what we do
with them is not indifferent and
is in our control so for example if we
think about elections
since we have some important elections
coming up here in america
you know you don't actually determine
your you know your vote counts
as we say everybody's pushing your vote
counts it's very important to get out
there your vote in the in the
you know practical scheme of things your
one single vote is not
the deciding vote that is going to
determine anything
but it you know figures into a big
basket of stuff that goes in there
and similarly what you put on social
media who you
whether you put a sign out in your yard
if you have a yard or not or in your
window
those are things that you could say are
in some respect
aspirational right meaning they they're
not going to change
the absolute outcome of things but they
play a part as an aggregate
in something and so somebody might be
tempted to say well see who's going to
be president or who's going to be
senator of my state or who's going to be
the local dog catcher
outside of my control i shouldn't worry
about it whatsoever
that's an example by the way of what
cicero
brings up in on fate as the lazy
argument we can come back to that in a
bit right and
um you know you don't control the
outcomes
you do control what you decide to do you
do control your actions
you can in fact vote and the stoic thing
to do
would be if there's any chance of you
know participating in some
some uh meaningful action go ahead and
do that that's that's in fact the right
thing to do
because we should be concerned about our
communities we should be concerned
about other people we should be
concerned about who's in charge
not to the degree that we allow it to
induce all sorts of
negative emotions right um
but to the point that we
can in fact make the right decisions
with what we have at hand with what is
in front of us
so the dichotomy of control is not
saying
you shouldn't be politically involved or
active or anything like that
and as a matter of fact here's another
thing i want to say about stoicism
stoicism is not reducible to one or two
principles
there are perhaps some philosophies out
there fewer than you would think
that you can do that with those are
usually misunderstanding
of philosophical positions stoicism
is a complex of a whole bunch of
different ideas and distinctions
and doctrines and you know if you want
to
do things from a stoic perspective you
need to learn those others and they kind
of
fit into each other and modify each
other so let's talk about some of the
ones that would
move us towards political engagement
and discrimination and good decision
making
one of these is the virtues there there
are four virtues acknowledged by the
stoics as
by platonists and epicureans and many
others as well aristotelians are kind of
the outliers in having more than four
main divisions of virtues the cardinal
virtues
and among those are justice
right justice is incredibly important
and if you
go to the stoic literature to see what
justice consists in
it's not just like not breaking the
rules it has to do with how we
apportion resources within society are
we doing so in a way that's
fair and reflective of you know
good distinctions that we want to make
or are we doing it in arbitrary ways
that are really unjust even if they have
to do with externals
we can we can apportion externals justly
or unjustly
you know so if we have a incredibly
stratified society
in which there are increasingly greater
and greater
distinctions of wealth and income and
access to resources
from a stoic perspective you know as
well as from a platonic perspective an
aristotelian perspective you're going to
notice this across virtue ethics
that's unjust and we should work against
that
we should work to you know as much as we
can
make things better to to fix those
things
obviously we don't control whether we
fix them entirely but
you know that's that's what we ought to
be doing justice also extends
to commitments if we've made commitments
we should fulfill
those commitments and we should you know
if we have the power to do so
try to make sure that other people
fulfill their commitments as well so
when we see you know businesses that are
allowed to come into an area and they
get tax breaks because they're going to
provide
all sorts of benefits for people in the
area and then they don't
stoic perspective is punish them take
action use the state
to do that we can talk about other
aspects of justice as well
justice has two sides to it says cicero
in on duties which by the way
coming from a stoic text that of
peneteus so although cicero himself is
not a stoic
on you know on duties is ostensibly a
pretty stoic text
and there he says that one side of
justice is what we can call strict
justice you know
making sure that there are fair
proportions enforcing the laws
making sure commitments are followed
even commitments by the way to enemies
you know just because somebody is a a
bad person
or hostile to you doesn't mean you can
treat them in any way you want according
to cicero and according to the stoics
but there's another side to it which is
that of beneficence of kindness
of of going beyond just what you have to
give
and making people's lives better it's
not an open-ended commitment to do
everything for everyone
cicero actually gives you some some
clear rules about that in
on duties and the stoics do talk about
how we ought to be benefiting
our common you know human beings on the
broadest scale our fellow citizens
and residents of our states our people
in our neighborhood people in our
families people in our
institutions like workplaces or
educational institutions
that is also part of justice and so that
is something that a person does have
some control over
you know fulfilling these requirements
of the virtue
stoicism is a virtue ethics if you want
to be a stoic
it doesn't just mean withdrawing
yourself from society
and pursuing your own private you know
happiness or interests
you're connected with the rest of
society and if we look at historical
stoics we see that
that is exactly what they did they
didn't withdraw as a matter of fact
they criticize a different group of
philosophers the epicureans for
doing exactly that withdrawing from all
of the networks of our
social and political and other
obligations
there's another virtue i think that's
particularly important to think about as
well i'm just going to move this because
i
notice it's sticking up here and that is
wisdom
we as human beings we are truth seekers
and we have an obligation not just to
seek the truth uh you might say in
quotes
that fulfills our own emotional needs or
satisfies what we want to do
you know um we really
we really have an obligation to develop
our minds
and to you know when there's a lot of
false information floating around out
there
call it out as the [ __ ] that it is
or the partisan attempts to try to get
stuff across
um we should be very concerned about
you know getting things right and being
truthful ourselves
and you know we should also be prudent
in another way
when it comes to the political in not
demanding
too much right we can certainly do good
and we can expect our politicians to
some degree
to do things that are good without
demanding utopian schemes
or holding those as the criteria against
which we're going to measure
you know actual political
doctrines programs things like that
prime example of this is uh universal
health care so we don't have anything
remotely like that
here in the united states except for a
select few like senators for example
who who get socialized medicine at our
expense
um and you know among developed
countries
um we're kind of an outlier in that way
and that we have a health care system
that is just a hot mess
it's not even a system it's an entire
set of interlocking systems
i don't have to go very deep into this
because anybody who's seen me talk about
this before you know exactly what i'm
referencing it's like that in terms of
um you know policing education we
here in america we we have so much
localism
that it's very difficult to get things
done and it's very difficult to have any
universal standards
and there's a lot of taking advantage of
people as as a
um consequence of that by the part of
the powerful
against the those who are much more
vulnerable to them
so having a universal health care system
would that solve everything
no would it be perfect well we can look
at the
developed countries in which there is
such a thing people do still fall
through the cracks
would it be better than what we have
right now yeah be way better
so this is sort of unless you have some
ideological commitments that stand in
the way
kind of a no-brainer from a stoic
perspective we would take care of people
we would use the tax resources that we
could be spending
instead on you know military adventures
and all sorts of wasteful spending
in other ways we could actually spend
that on health care and drastically
improve
the the health of the people in this
nation that would be a
prudent thing to do what would be
imprudent would be demanding that it be
perfect or we
can't enact it or elevating other things
to you know trump that by saying
oh it's going to keep you from choosing
your physician which turns out to be
[ __ ]
right [ __ ] and lies basically that
politicians who are against it
have been against it for the last 30
years because this is a topic we've been
talking about since the
the clinton era right um there's there's
a a
uh a lot of sort of bad arguments
floating around out there
it is not prudent from a stoic
perspective
to accept those arguments and spout them
forth
as if those are truth and should trump
having you know a good policy in place
as a matter of fact what is that from a
stoic perspective
a vice a vice of foolishness
so you know there's a lot of things
within the political sphere
where the virtues come to important role
and we should use those
as guidance or how stoic would in fact
behave uh you know those who routinely
lie about things
stoics would have a problem with that um
those who are engaging
in um actions that are clearly
you know to their benefit or the benefit
of just their group
against everybody else stoics would have
a problem with that
i do want to say something else too i
mentioned that you can see that stoics
did in fact
real stoics did have political
commitments um
there were some stoics who got exiled
for those commitments
uh and and some non-stoics as well
including like
cicero right uh uh you you find that
that not epictetus but um his teacher
musonius rufus
gets exiled right why because he's part
of this stoic resistance to
real tyranny not just pretend tyranny
you know
here in wisconsin we have we have the
you know people who
make arguments that wearing a mask is
tyranny i mean i wish they had a dose of
real tyranny
so they could put things in perspective
and then say holy [ __ ] was i wrong about
that
now i know what real tyranny's like i'm
gonna quit talking this stupid nonsense
and quit making such a big deal out of
doing something that's
beneficial not just for my fellow
citizens but my family as well
um so we can we can go on and on what
did the the
stoics actually do they took stands they
criticized people
epictetus has a great
um uh you know example of this where
he's criticizing a local official
for setting a terrible example
intervening
in a um uh contest about about who's the
best comedian
if i remember right you know so
epictetus is holding a local official
responsible for things
they were they were politically engaged
right uh
hadrian the emperor comes and visits
epictetus because he wants some advice
marcus aurelius of course is an emperor
and has to make
all sorts of difficult decisions seneca
is an adviser to
one of the you know worst emperors you
could get
nero and he tries to do the best that he
can
to steer nero away from you know you
know more crazy nonsense that he's
engaged in and eventually
falls fall of uh you know
nero and and uh why because he's a stoic
he takes a stand we can also think about
the
roman civil war you know this is a great
one for thinking about
you know we're obviously not in a civil
war but we can think about voting for
the least of two evils
you know you may not here in america we
do have third parties they're almost
totally useless
and usually um you know if you look at
them closely
they may have interesting platforms but
the people involved with them are
they leave something to be desired right
so we're stuck with the two
and you have to choose well which of
these if you're going to vote are you
going to
to support you know and as an
independent myself
i've voted for republicans and democrats
i've even voted third party at different
times
depends on what what race we're talking
about um
so let's think about what happened
during the roman civil war you had two
sides
because the triumphant broke down by the
way
cicero was invited to be one of the
people in the triumph for it so it would
have been a quad virument right four
person rule julius caesar uh pompeii
crassus uh and then it would have been
cicero and cicero said i can't work with
any of you because you're all scumbags
right you're all problematic cato as
well
also took a similar position now
what happened when there was a civil war
well it was caesar versus pompeii
neither one of which
were particularly good but caesar was
clearly worse
from the perspective of cicero and the
the
stoic cato because they lined up with
pompeii
they said well i'm not going to find an
ideal person to support in this but i'm
also not going to stand
on the sidelines and say that this is
perfectly
fine so
you know this is something to keep in
mind the examples
of the the stoics is something that are
relevant to
decision making i would say that you
know there's a lot of other things that
that we could bring up
somebody this is a great place to jump
into some of the questions because we've
got a few
that are touching on this by the way uh
irrelevant questions
i'm not going to bother with them
because we have
you know this is this is dedicated to a
particular set
of topics save those for amas and ask
those
at that time so uh mark says i'm
interested to hear your ideas on stoic
cosmopolitanism been thinking about that
a bit lately
so this is a really great question
cosmopolitanism
the stoics were not the first persons to
talk in terms of cosmopolitanism the
that is
my city or my political community being
the world the cosmos
um diogenes laertes tells it tells us
that diogenes the cynic
actually said something like that but
this is indeed
part of the stoic inheritance
there is this notion that you know
regardless of what political differences
we have
cultural differences you know the
history that we've been involved in
we are all human beings and we are all
part of
one vast as epictetus would say a cosmos
of humans and divine beings we might
clip the divine beings out of there in
some forms of modern stoicism
although the ancient stoics didn't and
say we're all
one fundamental community we are all one
race the human race right
and so we should think about our impact
on others we should not be for example
nationalists who are willing to say
screw everybody else
and um we can we can you know do
whatever we want
to them we can exploit them we can you
know demonize them we can go against
them
in in ways we also don't have to say
that that other people doing that is
okay
as well you know one of the things i do
want to point out too that i had wanted
to bring up
it's not stoic to expect everybody else
to be stoic
right uh this is a fundamental mistake
that a lot of people
getting introduced to to stoicism make
when they start
as with any other kind of you know
personal development thing they think oh
i've become this
therefore everybody in the world should
be judged according to the standards
that i have
no you work on your own stoicism first
uh sort of the
you know the christian analogy of that
would be
first get your own sermon on the mount
right
and your you know confirmation to those
principles
then start worrying about criticizing uh
everybody else
um for for not living up to those those
particular
principles right but yeah
cosmopolitanism is important if it were
to guide our decision-making processes
we would do things a lot differently we
would care about where our economic
supply chains go
we would be concerned about
sustainability
right in ways that many of us aren't we
would
reject um engaging in purely partisan
hold on to power at any you know in any
way possible
uh sort of politics which the
republicans are engaging in in spades
right now
but the democrats did back in the 90s
and early 2000s as well you know when
that sort of thing is happening
we should we should view that as wrong
and resist it
um cosmopolitanism this here's another
thing i want to say about
cosmopolitanism
cosmopolitanism in order to be practiced
doesn't always have to like look for the
most
exotic and far off corner of the world
you can practice it in your own
community look for who's marginalized
look for who has been left out look for
who has been thrown aside
and see what you can do for them that
would be practicing cosmopolitanism
you could even do this in your family
you know it may be that the black sheep
in your family has been rightly
ostracized because they're a complete
jerk
and toxic and nobody can deal with them
and they're abusive
but that might not be the case they
might have actually been pushed to the
margins
by the abuser who's still in the family
cosmopolitanism
would extend to taking that in
we can think about a prime example of
this that i just saw on twitter earlier
today
and it's a discussion that we've had
going for a long time in the educational
sphere is
how do we treat students there's a lot
of professors who are treating students
as if they're like
criminals you know just we're gonna wait
for them to screw up and then we're
gonna come down hard on them
about cheating on tests or you know uh
questions or things like that that's
that's you know
it's so far away from what it is to be a
genuine educator
and it's so punitive and to do this in a
time period when our students are
stressed the hell out because of social
distancing and covid19
and the shift to online which a lot of
professors are not doing a good job with
you know what we ought to be doing when
a student says
for example i had a student who um
has got some you know tough family
dynamic stuff going on
and who reached out to me and um you
know we had a conversation about it and
i i said you know i can't be obviously
your therapist
or counselor i want you to find somebody
there should be resources out there
but i can't at least be sympathetic to
your situation
my family is kind of big and kind of
messy as well
um i can i can relate to what you're
going through and
all you know i'm not going to grade your
stuff as late just try to get it in when
you can get it in when you have the
presence of mind to do so
that student told me you're the only
professor i've got who took that stance
as a matter of fact some of her other
professors said
hey there's this thing called stoicism
out there it'll help you you know be
more resilient
and then they they that was their only
suggestion to her what would a real
stoic do
i don't even claim to be a real stoic
i'm an eclectic who thinks that stoicism
is really important
and i incorporated in my stuff what
would it do you would be compassionate
you would actually take an interest in
the person that is part of
cosmopolitanism
treating other people as if they are
part of
your polis and the stoics go further and
talk about
oikios treating people as if they're
members of your family as if they're
part of your household
so i think that's probably enough about
about that
um incubus says i live in a small town
in russia uh there's none of this is
relevant to
to the stoic stuff so i'm going to skip
over that um
avarile goes back to the universal
healthcare thing and says
like that argument that universal care
would enslave doctors
yeah and as as a matter of fact i even
had a client who
was a specialist and and he would
sometimes tell me
about you know his worries about
enacting universal health care and that
was one of the arguments that that he
would bring forward
that it would like sort of tie their
hands and make them you know uh
uh unable to do anything and that's
nonsense look at the countries that do
have universal healthcare they also
still have private medicine which you
can pursue
on the side but if you're working for
the state yeah you got to follow some
state standards right uh they don't
appear to be particularly
problematic or onerous in most cases and
now there are some cases where we can
say aha
look at this you know this is this is
problematic or bad here
those are the exceptions i mean right
now
what what are the big problems with
medicine in the united states
number one is that doctors spend more
time uh
filling out forms and doing routine
paperwork stuff than they do
actually spending time with patients
that's a big red flag right there that's
a danger sign
another would be the fact that insurance
companies get to decide what
people are going to uh have and it's not
based on what's best for patients it's
based on what's best for stockholders
it's based on profits that's a problem
right
and we could say well maybe we're not
again we're not going to have a perfect
system
whose interest should be paramount this
is where the stoics would say
i don't know what's medicine about
what's the point of the art of medicine
this is also something plato says in the
in the republic book one two right
and aristotle talks about at different
points aristotle by the way from a
medical family
what is the point of medicine is it to
generate revenue
no the point of medicine there's
actually four main goals of medicine
i'm teaching biomedical ethics right now
so this is kind of top of mind
one is to you know prevent death or or
extend
life right another is to alleviate
suffering and pain
another is to
you know eliminate or help people manage
disease and another is to promote public
health
promote healthy lifestyles in people
none of those are about making a ton of
money
for aurora stockholders or anything like
that
so let's uh let's go on to the next one
uh
good or grown says epistemic
responsibility
uh is good yeah you can call it
epistemic responsibility you can also
talk about it as the virtue of of
prudence
and you know making sure that you're you
know not cluttering up your head with
all sorts of crazy nonsense
that makes it harder for you to make
good decisions right
so all right um
incubus asks a question that is is
kind of on on point here i've read
plato's republic he says democracy is
one of the worst forms of government do
you agree with him
so it's one of the bad forms of
government he doesn't say it's the worst
as a matter of fact it's the poikilos
regime you want to read book
book eight carefully um and it's
the worst is the tyranny right isn't
here any worse than democracy
um now what does plato mean by democracy
is
that what we mean by democracy you gotta
you gotta think through
this this sort of thing i mean even
aristotle's conception of democracy
is probably closer than what what plato
is talking about to what we mean by
democracy
and we don't live in anything that's
effectively like a democracy because we
live in something that's really more
like an uh
you know oligarchy or ola you know or or
sometimes even a kleptocracy
right where the those who have prestige
power
wealth get to use that to perpetuate
itself
have a way way more uh influence in
politics and undue influence
um we have a pretty flawed system here
and although we do have voting which is
a sign of democracy and people can serve
on juries which is also a part of
democracy
i wouldn't say that we have anything
remotely like
uh athens democracy going on here
we could say that it's closer to what
aristotle was talking about where you
have rule by the people
and for the benefit of you know the
people or classes of people
um rather than in sort of a narrow way
rather than for the benefit of the
entire society but
i think if aristotle will look at our
society he would say this is
an oligarchy this is not a democracy in
in most of our
uh states here in the united states and
in our country as well
all right anything says how can we rely
on the election process when the
american government has lied about so
many big things
that's kind of a non-sequitur i mean so
the american government which american
government right
there's no such thing as the american
government that has existed for
uh ages and ages there's a point that
aristotle points out you want to make a
distinction between
the particular regime and the
form of government don't you um you
could you could say that there
are policies that were started by one
regime
and then carried forward in another
regime oftentimes it's made worse
so you know for example some of the
anti-terrorist actions uh
under the bush regime were carried
forward by the obama regime i mean
anybody who
bought into that hope everything's going
to be different um they they weren't
paying attention
obama was a machine politician from
chicago
and you know not a big surprise to those
of us in the midwest who've been
following his career
that he was not this reformer that
everybody thought he was going to be
and so we can talk about you know the
the expansion for example of drone
warfare
um there there are you know some of the
things that people are complaining about
at present about um what what uh
homeland security and ice and border
patrol are doing under the trump regime
it's true that they were started on the
obama regime the trump regime actually
made them much worse
and you know talking about lying lied
about them as much as possible
it's not that the obama regime didn't
but what does it have to do with
trusting american elections
i mean is it the government that's
administering the elections each state
has its own thing and then
it's it's it's a process where you know
we we do have some
uh oversight granted the federal
election commission under the trump
administration has become incredible
incredibly corrupt and you know not
doing what it's supposed to be doing
that's a separate topic
um you know they they report the results
and you know all the
all the stations start playing them it's
it's not a perfectly transparent process
but it's hell of a lot more transparent
than land use processes isn't it so i
these these are not necessarily and
having this this universal skepticism
about it would not be a
thing to do you you weigh things um
but you can all right so
let's see here ben cloak new to stoicism
if stoicism sees human nature as a
collective one then doesn't advocate for
democracy
didn't say it it said that it's a
collective one i said it's
it's one that's you know inherently
political and
and we have a sort of drive towards
existing together it doesn't mean it's
collectivism or anything like that so
i'd be careful with the terminology um
but there's a better there's a better
question involved there
would contemporary stoics or if you
brought like cicero to the present day
or
cato or epictetus or marcus aurelius
marcus aurelius would be a great example
if you brought him into the present day
and said listen
here's all the stuff we know about human
nature that we didn't know about
back then here's a lot of history of
like human societies
and here's here's an example of you know
what democracy looks like today
would they be for some sort of
autocratic
rule by an emperor or would they be
for democracy or would they before some
other regime
i think that most of them would say well
you know democracy is good
we can't just have like you know single
issue everyone votes on every single
thing kind of democracy
but almost no place has ever had that or
if they did they didn't have it very
long a few of the italian city-states
you know
experimented with that there's there's
bits and pieces of that and
you know swiss cantons but it's it's not
a very common
thing um i think that personally i think
that
uh if if they were brought to the
present they probably would say yeah
democracy
doesn't work great in a lot of cases but
it's it's the way to go
in part because you want to have a voice
from the people you want to take in
multiple points of view you want
to ideally not just have sides warring
with each other but actually
compromising on issues
sort of stuff we were taught back when
we had civics classes in our in our
curriculum
all right um let's see
hovis says wondering if any 19th or 20th
century political thinkers reach back to
stoicism for
ideas more interested in the left marks
lennon gramsci
but whatever you've got i mean i don't
think anybody in the the
marxist tradition is looking to the
stoics
[Music]
that's a good question um
are there any big name political
thinkers
theorists who are
drawing upon the stoics i i can't think
of anybody who's like
drawing on them in any sort of
substantive way
i mean they may be drawing on ideas that
we could say dovetail
nicely with the stoics
and there are people out there in the
present in the modern stoic movement who
are you know taking positions and
explicitly drawing on
on stoic perspectives you know great
example when it comes to
environmentalism
kai whiting and his collaborator
i'm going to mangle his name leonidas is
it constabus
i don't have it in front of me so i'm
probably misremembering his name chris
gill
just in stoicon yesterday was talking
about environmental responsibility
um and he and and uh i
and kai and leonidas have collaborated
on on some stuff in the past
uh masa mo pigliucci if anyone follows
his his twitter feed
has uh taken some very clear positions
on on politics um
you know donald robertson has taken a
more socratic approach to that but he's
been pretty heavily involved if you
follow his twitter feed
lately right so um
that's a good question i i can't think
of anybody offhand
um as a matter of fact there's sometimes
kind of an animus against the stoic so
i'm going to go into a little bit of a
digression here in
uh what was what's been called like the
revival of virtue ethics and there's
good reasons why that's sort of a
provincial term because virtue ethics
never really went
away in other areas except in like
anglo-america anglo-american philosophy
um but in that revival there has been a
replication
of the 19th century narrative that hegel
is
is a great example of and this is where
they're getting things
basically wrong the idea was that you
know you had
ancient greece and in the hellenic era
before the hellenistic era
so when you have all these rival
city-states
people can like identify with their
city-state and it's a small enough
place where they can they can find their
meaning within there right so they're
all politically involved
and then you know the macedonian
conquest comes with philip uniting
greece
and then you know the the macedonian
wars
uh using the entire panoply of the greek
uh power against the persian empire the
the shattering of the persian empire the
new successor states
uh coming out of alexander's uh uh
generals the the diadoco right and
the the basic story is this people
quit feeling like they were part of a
local community
and now they're part of a larger
community where they can't really have
their own meaning and that's where
skepticism and stoicism and cynicism
and epicureanism arise as philosophies
for these rootless
individuals who don't really fit into
their city-state
and that's that's an interesting history
it turns out to be mostly [ __ ] when
you actually look at documents right
when you start probing into it and you
start seeing that no
people were still very involved in their
communities
now they're just dealing with a
different sort of thing i think that
that
buying into that buying into that that
fundamentally wrong narrative
made a lot of people who would otherwise
be interested in and attracted to
looking at the stoics made them say ah
there's nothing really to be seen there
as a matter of fact i will mention
there's an article by
a.a long that's anthony long and i don't
remember the title exactly
i should have a top of mind because i
want to do some writing about it
down the line and he's criticizing
mcintyre
uh for getting the stoics wrong about
this very issue
and saying that the stoics actually
compromise a virtue ethics tradition
that's a
uh you know very clearly committed to to
communities and stuff like that
so you know when somebody even like
mcintyre
misses it or hana rent i would say
misses it then you know
we've got to do some some reconstruction
so there's probably a lot of
opening right now to to working on those
sorts of ideas
all right let's see what else we've got
here um
mark says the stoic concept of
cosmopolitanism sounds like it
intersects well with the christian
concept of charity
yeah if it's extended broadly the
charity understood
not just as beneficent giving right
which is one of the
actions but as the fundamental virtue of
love love for others love for the
neighbor
um yeah there's there's parallels there
i would say
um all right skip says
cheating contest is an option one takes
when they're not being
stoic educators would much much rather
have a student ask for help instead
take the week around cheating
plagiarizing
and he's got a few other things but i'm
gonna yeah i'm gonna respond to that
yeah you're right about that a lot of
students do cheat and plagiarize
not because they're horrible people who
want to take advantage of the system
because they run out of time
and they're trying to juggle a bunch of
stuff and so they they screw up right
and um you know not that many
at least going from my uh uh experience
if you set things up right and minimize
the opportunities for
cheating it becomes less and less of a
problem you know and if you explain to
students why i'm having you do these
things
like even multiple choice tests like i i
have an explanation for my students
you are doing this because i'm testing
you at a low level to make sure you're
actually doing the reading
and and by the way my my multiple choice
quizzes that i have students take weekly
they can take them as many times as they
want you know
the whole the whole point is to get them
to have like a low level
uh understanding um basic concept
right and then build off of that those
aren't the only things that
we do um skip goes on i treat all my
students as if they're part of the polis
if they want to show their best natures
i'm right there
to help them realize that if they
struggle i help them both with realism
and idealism compare and contrast when
they come to me for help
that's good that's that's uh admirable
that's the kind of teacher
that you you want to be and so many of
my
students are reporting to me even in
institutions that are supposed to be
supportive of the students that that's
not what they're getting
and it's kind of unfortunate so
all right um sartak wasn't plato a pro
totalitarian if stone made it is stone
made a good argument showing that what's
your opinion i think that's complete
[ __ ]
i mean um plato
is so you have to first of all you can't
just throw the word totalitarian around
you gotta
you gotta have a good conception of what
it is um if plato's republic
the the place that he's you know trying
to realize were to be realized would
that be totalitarian that's the first
thing that you can ask
and i think you can make a good argument
for why it's not
you know despite popper despite i
haven't read this this stone person but
i can't imagine any improves on on
popper in this respect
um these are misreadings of plato and
usually deliberate misreading so that
people have a nice boogeyman to attack
um in the case of popper i would say you
know the trauma of like living through
actual totalitarian you know
uh regimes and and history right
um but you look at the rest of what
plato has to say and you're not going to
get that
right it's best to view plato as a
critic of existing social structures as
is aristotle aristotle who did
examinations of the constitutions of all
the available greek city-states
in the politics says not a single one of
them is actually good
and he lays out a you know more uh
you know more or less elaborated view of
what an ideal city would look like
so i no i i mean that's kind of a
non-starter um
all right nathaniel how would you view
the anti-universal
healthcare argument that a free private
company based health care system is
better as it encourages competition and
improves overall quality
just look at what we got i mean
this this this one i mean we've done
that now
for about 40 years and
what's it produced misery
i mean it's been good for a couple
people we are
just abysmally bad i mean part of the
reason why we couldn't coordinate a
covid response
is because of our shitty health care
system that is exactly what you're
talking about right there
um this this whole note this whole bug
buzzword of
competition and improve overall quality
that has not been
the case so yeah
um gutter groan what is the argument
cicero made about helping everyone that
you mentioned it wasn't an argument it's
claims that he's making
go to on duties book one and read the
stuff there
about justice it's a long set of
passages
where he's detailing um what what you
know justice actually looks like
um
blah slav says you said you were
eclectic what is the what is the
then the background or measure of your
collecting
oh okay so what you're asking me how do
i assimilate things i try to figure out
which ones seem
on on the whole worth keeping and
overall right
there's eclecticism in the sense of like
laying out a smorgasbord and saying i'm
going to pick one of these in one of
these and one of these
and then there's eclectic and like
bringing whole systems together and
saying
where are these compatible where do i
have to make a decision and say i think
the aristotelians got this right the
stoics
got this wrong like for example on on
anger and to what degree
right so there's eclectic and then
there's eclectic
and you you use um there's an a single
rule that you use for that you kind of
like see well what fits in well and what
seems to make the most
sense um
all right gutter groan was is camus
stoic
kamu is not a stoic who is a as an
absurdist
or if you like an existentialist in the
broad sense and yes i know
that camus says that he's not an
existentialist
and that's sort of like you know people
who claim not to be in a particular
movement that they're very closely
connected with
and draw upon saying that they're not in
that movement so you got to be a little
bit you know careful
about about reading that kamu thinks
that the existentialists
are either the atheist existentialist
like like sartan to bouvoir who he
breaks with
largely on political lines or it's the
religious existentialists
like um chest off uh who nobody reads
anymore unfortunately
kierkegaard and yaspers or it's it's
some other people but kamu is really
an existentialist now the more
interesting question is is
existentialism
compatible with stoicism and the answer
is yes
to certain points right there's reasons
why they're different
isms they're not going to be perfectly
compatible but there is a lot of uh
interconnection right personal
responsibility is part of that
understanding that we're thrown into
situations that we don't ourselves
decide but we still have a
responsibility to act
the notion that you can improve yourself
through deliberate attention to what
you're doing
your responses changing those responses
common to both existentialists
and stoics i would even say a
i would even say a sort of like
high-minded
um view that that we should
um at least for some existentialists we
should
uh be good to our fellow human beings
that's their and kamu very strongly
you know it's also there in the stoics
all right
let's see here ben says i think kamu
would look down on stoicism as stoicism
entails absolute standards and inherent
purpose
i wouldn't say that camus looks down an
awful lot that's not the
way i would characterize things
entails absolute standards
that's a weird way to talk about about
it but sure yeah that that
that's fine um and and stoicism does
think that human beings do have an
inherent telos as do all virtue
ethicists don't they
pretty much if they're any good as
virtue ethicists um stoicism doesn't
have a sort of you know
uh cookie cutter simplistic approach to
that
and i think there's a lot of overlap
between camus or
or other existentialists and and the
stoic approach to things
and i think camus could say you could
have certainly endorsed stoicism
as one of the ethics of quantity if you
wanted to right i mean
you want to actually read the
mythosyphysis closely and see what kamui
has to say about
particular ways of going about things
so um let's see here prohem
i'm just starting to learn about
stoicism worried about the stoic idea of
duty
like epictetus is an example of the son
obeying the bad father
seems to say people shouldn't speak out
against power yeah if you misread it if
you're if you're only focusing on that
you don't read what the other things the
stoics are saying
and think about the implications of that
and you know we also want to be careful
when it comes to some of these things to
realize that they are
culturally dependent epictetus also says
a man should have a beard so all of you
guys who don't have beards
you're being too ladylike is that real
stoicism do we want to hold on to that
probably not right epictetus is saying
you have a choice
you have a choice how you look at your
father i mean you could take the choice
to say
this guy is abusive i'm going to abuse
him back aristotle
actually has an example of a guy who
dragged his father
up to the the boundary marker of the
estate and then when
he was you know criticized for being
abusive to his father he said well
that's what this guy did to his
that's what his father did to him he did
to his father so it's okay for me to do
that right
um you know epi you know stoicism
doesn't say stay in abusive
relationships that you've recognized as
abusive just for the sake of the
relationship
that's a possibility you could also say
that you can stand up for yourself
within that relationship and probably
should
right because that's also justice so
there's there's there's ways of
addressing this it's also like you know
when people look at epictetus
uh the famous thing where he says you
know when you kiss your wife or child
remind yourself what they are so you're
not going to be sad when they die
you got to read it within the the
context of the rest of the passage he
says
those who you are fond of those who you
feel familial affection towards
this is something that you can do and it
doesn't say that you shouldn't you know
think that it's a bad thing that they
they die at all right
um it's just not bad in the the the
sense that it has to compel you to all
sorts of weeping
and tearing your clothes and stuff like
that so
we want to contextualize these these
difficult
passages and usually like with most
robust
virtue ethics perspective where is the
answer to it somewhere in the texts you
know
um all right
uh valdrum could i outline the key
stoics and their ideas
i'm just going to tell you who the key
stoics are and then you can do the work
of
figuring out what their ideas are as you
go to read them
i mentioned the big three seneca epic
fetus
marcus aurelius epictetus is my favorite
but a lot of people like marcus aurelius
i think he's easier to read and less
systematic
seneca is also well worth reading you
probably want to read epictetus
teacher musonius rufus we do have
lectures by him and some fragments
you want to read hirocles who we have
some some texts by as well
citroen is very important although he
wasn't a stoic
on duty on the nature of the gods on the
ends
on divination on fate those are texts
that you would want to check out
probably also on the republic because
he's talking about
natural law there which he's getting
from the stoics
and then there's other things that you
can read as well
obviously you know are these all the
stoics no we've lost a lot of their
texts we don't have the text
of zeno the founder of the school we
don't have the text of the third
main stoic chrysippus who is apparently
one of the most prolific authors of
antiquity
we don't have the text of the middle
stoix posidonius and pennatius but
that's all right we have we have plenty
of stuff to work with
so you know you can you can certainly
check them out
uh mark asks what does some of the
stoics have to say about
educating people into the political life
that's a gap
that is certainly a place the stoics
don't actually tell us
that much about education of
children and of young adults in general
and so that's where modern stoicism has
to fill in
a lot of gaps and i think there's plenty
of room for
research projects along those those
lines
they seem to i mean again we're missing
a lot of stoic texts so
was it covered in some of those things
that we've lost we don't really know
um some of seneca's works are in effect
attempts to educate which didn't work
nero on anger and on clemency
those are right there to to uh
you know to uh help out
um we don't even know if nero actually
cared about them or read them
unfortunately
all right um david says regarding cicero
on duties he argues it's not morally
wrong to kill a tyrant does he ever
discuss how to assess whether one is
under a tyrant or not
yeah i mean
what do you think he thought caesar was
right
um or what do you think what do you
think he thought solo was i mean
he's got speech after speech after
speech and letters and
all sorts of other works so does he does
he ever give like a checklist okay
if you if you cross this line you you're
a tyrant if you're not you're good and
we we can't kill you
no i mean it kind of presumes some
common sense
on the part of people involved
but i mean you can read through his
corpus and find
all sorts of discussions of this so
all right um let's see
scrolling down a little bit it's more
irrelevant questions um
kyle asked do you think the
environmental movement is well suited to
encourage a recognition
of a common humanity how would a stoic
engage with those who do not accept
science
so let's start with the last thing
you're not going to find a single person
who doesn't accept some science if
you're using technology
you accept some science right if you if
you think that
maybe you shouldn't drink mercury you
probably do so because
you've learned that it's poisonous and
you didn't do so by like direct
observation of other people drinking
mercury
you're relying on the science right so
people who don't
accept science it's selective about what
they don't accept
they usually accept a great amount of
science as far as they understand it now
most people's understanding of science
is awfully hazy even if you're going to
like stay
up on research and like read the studies
rather than read journalists reviews of
the studies
which are often uh inflated it's it's
tough to do so none of us
even scientists don't know all of
science right
but there's nobody who is like totally
anti-science because they're relying on
technology
which is a product of science and
they're relying on a lot of things that
are coming to
them from science as basic beliefs it's
usually like they don't accept
climate science right uh and they've got
like some alternative theory that they
they buy into right um there isn't
man-made
uh climate change there is climate
change but it's all cyclical
caused by the sun right or you know well
maybe there is human-caused climate
change but it's not as bad as we think
you always find them hedging and hedging
and hedging right well maybe the models
aren't
are good or the scientists were
corrupted by money or
blah blah blah blah blah so and similar
things with the anti-vaccination
a similar thing going on with all the
all the nut jobs out there who think
that you shouldn't you know mask up
and that masks prevent you from from
being able to breathe
or you know they're actually going to
give you covid19
okay that's clearly anti-science in a
certain respect
right um what do you do with them i
don't think there's a one single blanket
thing
one thing would be you keep saying no
you're wrong and we're not going to let
you have any decision-making power
if we can help it unfortunately we're
stuck with with a lot of people over
here
who are um pretty pretty you know
imprudent from a stoic perspective
pretty foolish when it comes to that and
that leads to them being unjust and
cowardly
and intemperate as well so um
what do you do with them you can you can
resist them you can keep you know trying
to
go against them on twitter you know uh
there's
ways in which you in other social media
you report those people right
you take part in that ecosystem now
coming back to to this though um
here we go is the environmental movement
well suited to encourage a recognition
of a common humanity
i would say there isn't an environmental
movement there's movements that are kind
of loosely connected
if you're um talking about like deep
ecology people
i mean i don't think they care whether
there's a common humanity
they they tend to see humanity as the
main problem
if you're talking about things that are
you know more
in the the mainstream of saying well you
know we should think in terms of
sustainability you know
think about the the um triple
uh bottom line approach in business
ethics right where we look at not just
profits
but we look at people and we look at
planet um
the three p's as we call it can an
approach like that recognize a common
humanity i would say it actually
presupposes yet um
and so yeah that that could do it but i
i don't know that all the
environmental um
perspectives would do that somebody like
uh you know my fellow wisconsinite aldo
leopold with the land ethic i would say
can recognize that but then it
recognizes that we're part of a larger
matrix and this is where it's good to
point out
the ancient stoics were were wrong and
we need to
go go beyond them the ancient stoics
like
pretty much everybody else in ancient
society
and virtue ethics thought that rational
beings that is human beings and
and divine beings are radically distinct
from all the other
sentient beings the animals and plants
and that there's a
set of sort of like um levels of being
and so irrational being is there
for rational being there's a teleology
to it
and so we can now some people could
interpret as we can do whatever the hell
we want with the environment or with
with animals or stuff like that and i
think that
you know to begin with there's two
issues that come up there
one is we we need to think well what is
it to be rational
and do any of the higher animals that
are not human
do they cross into that line this is
something by the way that kai whiting
and chris gill have been
thinking about um and i i've had
conversations with them about that
should we look at apes you know the
higher apes or the cetaceans or
elephants as crossing into the the
boundary of rationality and therefore
being protected as rational beings
so there's that aspect and then we
should also think about
you know how how we in the ways in which
we're mismanaging the environment how
we're affecting other fellow human
beings
as well all right um
let's see here
looks like it skipped a little bit uh
ben cloak where does traditional
stoicism deviate from aristotelian
virtue ethics is it still rooted in
fulfilling eudaimonium
so couple things right there um it
doesn't deviate from aristotelian virtue
ethics because it didn't come from
aristotelian virtue of ethics the
original stoic
doctrine is coming from zeno who did not
study with the aristotelians he studied
with
the cynics with the megarians and with
the platonic school
didn't study at the lyceum as far as we
know um so there
you think of them not as one deviating
from the other
but rather as parallel and rival paths
um you know there's all sorts of ways in
which stoicism
is different than than aristotelian
virtue ethics they're both
robust virtue ethics they have different
uh anthropologies
aristotle has essentially a a two-part
anthropology you know you have the
rational part which is subdivided into
two
or perhaps more then you have the
irrational part and then there's some
other parts on the side like fontasia
stoics thought that there's a different
anthropology
for the human being where it's all
really emotions are felt in the rational
part um
they didn't accept a doctrine of the
mean uh except
with some exceptions seneca maybe a
little bit
depending on which which letter you're
looking at
although seneca has to do a little bit
of tap dancing around the issue
right where they're aristotle very
clearly you know
the mean is absolutely central in virtue
ethics
um conception of eudaimonia aristotle
thinks that you need
virtuous activity plus relationships
plus a certain amount of wealth
stoics say virtue by itself is
sufficient
so there's all sorts of resources out
there that can give you
insights into this they're both
you know aiming at eudaimonia they're
both providing you with with a lot of
useful insights and practices i find
that in large part
they can be effectively combined and
sort of like some of the middle stoics
in that respect like posidonius or
penatus
who thought that you needed to
incorporate insights from the platonic
and aristotelian
perspectives cicero did too so
you know those those are some some uh
ways that yeah they're both
they're both connected i do want to say
when we talk about traditional stoicism
in the present
there are people out there who are
called the traditional stoics and they
differ
from other stoics in the modern times
that we call modern stoics
in that traditional stoics are committed
to
ideas that the stoics had about the
cosmos
about human beings about you know what
they called stoic physics
that other modern stoics aren't
necessarily committed to
for example that the universe is one
vast complex organism
or that there is a divine mind that we
can call zeus
out there guiding everything within this
this
process and that it's guided
providentially traditional stoics say
you cannot compromise on that
and modern stoics say no it's it's it's
up to you you can
you can you can be a theist you can be
an atheist you can be some sort of
pantheist
these are all possibilities within
within stoicism
all right um olivia asks i guess i'd ask
what is stoicism's role in psychotherapy
um the cognitive revolution is
influenced by
stoicism you know if you look at
rational emotive behavior therapy and
then later cognitive behavior therapy
epictetus plays a major role in
ellis's ideas lesser role in beck's
stuff but plays some role donald
robertson has shown
that there were some french
psychotherapists early in the 20th
century
who were using stoicism as well um
it didn't have much of a a place in in
the
psychoanalytic movement
and in some respects stoicism could
provide something that would
would give further structure to the
cognitive
movement as well including you know
later later developments
like um acceptance and commitment
therapy or things like that
so it plays some role um
i don't think a lot of psychotherapists
necessarily know a lot about um
about uh stoicism but there are some who
do especially those in the
rational emotive behavior therapy uh
school and
movement um good example that would be
walter and i might be butchering his
last name matt weichuk
who i've interviewed before and a good
guy
had a lot of cool conversations with him
he's spoken at stoicon before
so yeah um
andre is endcaridian prescribing to
ourselves some character and demeanor
epictetus advises be mostly silent or
speak what's needful in a few words but
even he doesn't
adhere to his advice um epictetus had a
role of being a teacher
so that doesn't apply to teachers he's
not giving
them that advice he's giving that to
people who are like beginning
stoicism the end caridian is by the way
assembled by epictetus's student aryan
right so it's not epictetus himself
writing this
and it's compiled from the discourses
which are much longer work that you want
you want to take a look at usually
anytime you find
like i was saying earlier anytime you
find something really puzzling
read the text more and you're going to
find stuff that you can correlate to it
stoicism is a
is a system um
[Music]
voldrim says can you see a connection
between stoic teachings and early
christian sects i wouldn't say sex
um because i would say that's coming
about later on unless you mean like the
different
uh heresies
meaning choice meaning you know going
off in this direction rather than this
direction
i don't see a connection between
stoicism and those but i do see a
connection between stoicism
and what later on comes to be you know
uh sort of the orthodox
you know in a broad sense christian
approach to things
um it's good to remember that the
early church fathers were for the most
part neoplatonists
and neoplatonists are not just about
plato
they often have assimilated stoic and
aristotelian ideas
and brought them together with platonism
into some sort of whole then you add
christianity into that
and you get quite a few stoic insights
and ideas getting brought into
christian thought that way add to that
the fact that many of these
um uh early christian writers were also
philosophers like justin martyr
loctancias or clement of alexandria who
know the stoics from having read them
augustine's another great example right
augustine mentions the stoics at a
number of points
as well as cicero as well as other other
authors
um so you know they're they're engaged
with stoic thought this is one reason
perhaps why stoicism
dies out as an independent school it's
already been successful in getting
it it's you know into um
mainstream christian thought and
practice at that time
the other thing to keep in mind too is
that monasticism is incredibly important
in early christianity
from about you know say the third
century on
and stoicism including some stoic
practices and ideas
uh made its way into a good bit of
monastic literature and practices
often in ways that are you gotta like
kind of read between the lines say oh
well yeah
they're i see where that's coming from
you know
so there's there's a lot of of that
going on then there were also stoic
texts that these these christian
uh thinkers were particularly monks
in the west who were the ones preserving
uh written culture
were reading and transmitting seneca
being one of them um discussions of
stoicism in cicero
being another um you know
epictetus and coridian was found
in in some monasteries they would they
would change the words around so
socrates becomes christ
and the philosopher becomes the monk
right but it's still the same text
so there's there's a lot of that being
preserved
and then of course in the renaissance
you know
the renaissance consists in in part is
like a yes a rebirth of learning
but where does this come from part of it
is like text coming from the um
eastern roman empire which is still
surviving but languishing at the time
um i think if i remember right marcus
aurelius's meditations comes from
comes from the east some of it is also
rediscovering manuscripts
in monastic libraries where they kind of
just lost track of what they had and
these scholars would go around
and and get all that so yeah there's a
lot of connections
um mark says any stoic exercises you
could recommend to deal with voting
anxiety yeah okay that's that's
that's a great question so there's a lot
of people who are very anxious
about the results of voting
and we also have to worry about election
violence
this time around and intimidation and
whether or not sides are going to
concede
so you know i would say that one of the
things that you can do is what's called
negative visualization
um and this can this is a common stoic
practice it consists in
you know sort of thinking to yourself in
a controlled environment
before you're dealing with the stuff
about what are the things that you're
anxious about what are you worried is
going to happen what are you
afraid will be the the result
and it has a couple different effects
one can be by thinking this out ahead of
time you know and and feeling the
feelings that come with it and then
dealing with those feelings
when the real thing happens it's not as
bad your reaction
may not be as as strong to it
another is you can think about well
would it really be as bad as i'm making
it out to myself if you like take the
thing
that you're so afraid of and you like
turn it around
and you visualize it and you're like oh
actually this this is not going to kill
me
um this is not going to be the end of
everything my emotional reaction
is excessive doing that can actually
help you to feel
that excessive emotional reaction less
and then you can also think about
something else and this is coming
straight out of epictetus and cradian
what resources do i have to deal with
this what would a
virtuous response be like and do i have
the
the the beginnings or the seeds of those
virtues within me can i
can i approach these things you know in
a prudent in a just in a courageous way
or am i condemned just to be the prey of
my emotional responses
so that's one thing i think that could
be quite helpful another
very helpful story practice is what we
call taking a pause when somebody
says something you know and there's an
immediate impression coming at you
fontasia impression appearance these are
ways of of translating imagination is
another way
you can say wait a second is this what
it presents itself to me as
or am i adding some value judgments here
am i adding some assumptions i need to
be
i need to like say hold on a second let
me look at you closely
it could turn out to be completely true
right somebody somebody reports
uh you know for example recently we had
a plot to kidnap the governor of our
neighboring state
uh michigan and you're like what
really uh white you know white
supremacist uh
gun nutters are coordinating to actually
like go and
get the governor and do god knows what
to her
you could say okay let's let's look at
what's actually being
said here okay so it's not like an open
revolt where we'd have to be like all
right let's let's all
man the barricades or something like
that um
it's you know it's a small cell of
clearly
uh devoted and clearly deluded
individuals who thought that that would
be a good thing
to do wrongly so unjustly so
and um it turns out it was the fbi
who um
you know who investigated and and who
arrested these people
we had another arrest recently too by
the way wisconsin resident
who is involved in this um so you know
you take a pause and it could turn out
well it is true it did happen or it
could turn out to be
fake news right um so you know that
that's another practice
another thing that i think is quite
helpful is
um trying to
to moderate your own responses to people
that you think are
wrong-headed or or opposed right
and this doesn't mean that you have to
treat them with kid gloves or you have
to always give them the benefit of
the doubt or something like that it's
not really about doing justice to them
so
much it's about not allowing yourself to
get so worked up that you can't
effectively respond right so when
somebody does something wrong epictetus
can
can say to you they're doing that
because on some level they think that's
right
now that doesn't mean that it is right
just because they think it's right
that's a sign of how screwed up they are
right um but that doesn't mean that you
have to have a response of like
anger or hatred or disgust to them
because that's actually damaging to you
you can condemn them
you can call them names if you want to
it's perfectly fine from a stoic
perspective
to call a person who's objectively an
[ __ ] an [ __ ] it's perfectly fine
to say somebody is
corrupt you know cowardly in the pockets
of this this or that lobby that's that's
perfectly fine
what really matters is why you're doing
it
you know you're taking a stance in the
political sphere some of these are
actually kind of object
objective words calling somebody corrupt
when they actually are corrupt
is is calling a spade a spade right a
shovel a shovel
so you know there there's that but you
you don't want to be like so
emotionally invested that it's it's
getting you upset and you're
you know furiously typing away you know
all these these screeds to to people
in social media um there are good
reasons to take you know direct action
um but it has to be thought out
rationally
right it shouldn't be a knee-jerk
response as seneca points out
anything that you can do out of anger
that's that's right to do you can do
using practical reason
and practical reason will probably carry
you
through way better than anger will
all right um
let's see here
luca asks about a lacan thing
uh we don't have any other questions so
so i'll take this is stoicism at odds
with lacan as it resists desires before
lacan desires the very origin of the
subject you're using desire in two
different ways there
and you should you should think that
lacan doesn't
every every reference to desire is not
desire at the origin of the subject
so no the answer is no in that case
um and and you know lacana is way more
complicated than that there's plenty of
overlap actually
not just between stoicism and laconian
psychoanalysis but psychoanalysis in
general i think that
you know psychoanalysis has been
rejected by a lot of the
the psychotherapeutic community in
recent years
um and and they've thrown out way too
many babies with some some clearly
stained bath water in doing so because
the idea of carrying out depth analysis
particularly when looking at you know
where a person's desires
demands imperatives all those sort of
things
are coming from paying attention to the
process
of transference in psychotherapy or in
coaching
all of these are good insights that i
think stoics
uh can take on and use for their
philosophy as a
way of life so all right uh
jordan says uh people
often think of politics in terms of
ethics and respond with disgust
i don't think that's effective i think
uh thinking of politics in terms of
ethics is important we we should
you know if politics ever just
degenerates into mere power
we're in trouble right and that'll
always be to the benefit of those who
have
elite status and can manipulate the
system if everything becomes
transactional then we've got problems
but yeah the emotion of disgust is not a
particularly
helpful one that said calling somebody
disgusting
can be a good political move you know
looking at some of the lies that are
being told they really
are disgusting in an objective sense
that doesn't mean we have to have a like
gut level
experience of disgust although you know
this is interesting
tim laban who is a practicing
psychotherapist
good friend and colleague of mine he is
he and i have been talking about this
for a while
because he and i are working on some
stuff having to do with stoicism and
emotion
and our view both of our views is that
emotional responses are not to be like
gotten rid of altogether
they're just not to be trusted as the
thing to carry us through
so an initial response of disgust to
some things
may be helpful but then you go beyond
the disgust then eventually that's not
what's
carrying on the decision making for you
practical rationality is
right and the virtues are but that could
figure into it
i mean the contemplation of finding
child pornography
on the um laptop or
computer of one of my colleagues should
actually
provoke a sense of disgust if it doesn't
might be something wrong with me right
in my case of course it does
but i shouldn't just be acting on the
basis of that disgust
right all right um
mark asks um could you make a stoic
argument to police
given the school's appeal to law
enforcement that could help mediate the
issue of police brutality that's a good
question
we do have a lot of very out of control
police and we have a lot of police who
themselves may not be engaging in
evil let's just call it straight out
evil behavior unjust
brutal behavior but are going along with
it maintaining the thin blue line
any good cop would want to see the bad
cops go away that's part of what makes
you a good cop
if if there are indeed good cops in bad
organizations
they would want to see those
organizations
changed for the better now can you make
an argument um
i i wouldn't say an argument i would say
a set of approaches that would include a
number of different arguments and
appeals
and i would say right off the bat expect
to
expect to be told that oh this is
impractical
oh this is foolish oh those bad people
over there we got to do something
there's a lot that has to be undone um
one of the things i would say one of
probably one of the vices that you could
go in on
is cowardice and and it's correlative
courage
police have it's clear their training
is is harmful to them and to other
people
by telling them that they're likely to
face all of these horrible situations
they use it's sort of like the old
driver's ed stuff where you try to scare
people into driving well
show them all these terrible car crashes
police get fed
a diet of look at what those criminals
are going to do to us
and then you know then they they're also
fed this thing of well you can shoot
somebody
and so long as you say i was in fear for
my life
we'll let you off attacking that
would probably be the most effective
single means for changing things um
saying that real cowards don't real
courageous people
don't hide behind guns and lines about
being in fear for their life
they evaluate things situation by
situation there are probably
circumstances
where a courageous cop will have to
shoot somebody
they're way fewer than what we currently
have there's no reason why police should
be armed to the teeth
carrying out you know no knock raids or
going after protesters who are who are
not being violent
um police should also be cracking down
on
on the people who are bringing in guns
to these protests
uh rather than collaborating with them
so i think there's a lot that could be
said there
um and we probably could in fact
um make some some arguments and perhaps
i
should be doing that you know um i've
got like a good audience to bounce this
off of my
my my dad is a former police chief
um and he's a rational one as well who
looks at his fellow police chiefs
and says wow they're really irrational
on things like legalizing drugs or
stuff like that so maybe there's a maybe
there's a good point to be doing that i
know that the people out there who are
doing
intersections between stoicism and
policing some of them are doing good
work
others i look at it and i'm like this is
problematic you know
um so that's actually a great question
for
like a program um
let's see jordan says so let the disgust
orient oneself but don't let it over
saturate reason
that's a good way to put it yeah you
have to use reason to keep the passions
in accordance with with reason um
tm says how do you reconcile nietzsche's
objection of stoicism that they want
nature to conform to their will or
virtue ethics in the political and
democratic field
i don't i think nietzsche is wrong about
stoicism
um and i think it is kind of a kind of a
cheap shot
he's got a different conception of
nature that he's criticizing them for
people always want to bring that up
and um you know they never question
whether nietzsche is right or wrong
about that
uh here's a good question from glock is
stoicism a cold world view
so this is the one we're going to go out
on because i see we're at like uh
close to time and and i gotta go shoot
some other videos
uh frankly before the packers game
starts so i'm kind of on a timetable
stoicism shouldn't be a cold world view
this is this is actually a great
question
a stoic should in fact have
um affection towards other people this
is totally clear
in classic stoic texts other people have
put forth this idea about stoic remember
i began this by talking about
lowercase s versus actual uppercase s
stoicism
lowercase s stuff is the cultural
representation of stoicism as a trait
of being detached unemotional not caring
about other people
enduring pain stuffing the feelings down
and that's all [ __ ]
i don't care if william james thinks
that's the case william james is wrong
right william james didn't pay close
enough attention love william james but
not every author is getting things right
if you read
marcus aurelius i mean i don't know how
you could read
aurelius's meditations where he talks
about affection and love
over and over and over again and think
that it's cold right if you read
epictetus
talking about familial affection futile
storge
if you read seneca if you read all these
other
thinkers and if you read the digest of
stoicism where they say even
eeros erotic love can be a good thing
that the sage
ought to feel there's no way you're
going to have this
this point of view so why is that point
of view so common
misrepresentations of the stoics i think
there's a lot of people out there
who like that idea of lowercase s
stoicism
because it appeals to them as being
tough guys you know
but it's at odds with genuine stoicism
and so this is a great place
to uh to bring it to a close thanks for
all of your
your questions i'm glad to you know um
be able to use them as fodder for my own
my own talking about this stoicism
really does have some serious political
implications
um the last thing i'm going to say stoic
week
starts tomorrow and this will be they
started it in
2012. so this is our our ninth time
around
if you haven't enrolled in the stoic
week course and you want to find out
what it's like to
live as a stoic this is a prime
opportunity to do so
just google stoic week course it'll pop
right up
it's free you can do whatever you want
it comes with a handbook it comes with
exercises to do each day i'm going to
shoot out a message to all of my
students about it
because it can be quite helpful i do it
every year even though i've been
studying stoicism now for decades and
been
part of the modern stoic movement in an
official way for five years
um i do it as sort of like an
opportunity to do some like fine
tuning right you check in and see see
how you're doing
um and and actually my my wife and i
i'm pointing this way because she's
downstairs we do it together and it's
fun to do
with other people obviously a little bit
difficult to do in our covid 19 times
you can't get together in groups
so but it's worth checking out um
we will also i'm going to put in a plug
we have stoicon x midwest
coming up next saturday it's an all-day
online event it's free you can just
google stoicon x midwest and the
eventbrite should show up for it we've
got a great lineup of speakers
we're going to have some panels
including an ask the expert panel
that we're going to have some some
pretty cool
people on with and we're even doing
lightning talks where people send in
short videos that i'm going to compile
into one big video
that we're going to play about different
aspects of of stoicism
so if you're interested in that check it
out there's other stoic on x events
running all the way into late uh late
november
this is the season of stoicism as i was
saying a little bit earlier
sounding a little bit facetious but it
really is so if you want to know more
about stoicism this is a really
excellent opportunity for you to get in
on that
um like i said you can find all that
stuff easily just by googling it so
thanks to all of you for joining in and
uh
i'll see you in some other events i'm
not sure what i've oh i've got
a few other things coming up later this
month the worlds of speculative fiction
of course and
i'd have to look at the calendar to see
what else but i'll see you in the ether
and some other events